Aughdubillahi mina shaytana Rajeem Bismillahir Rahmanir Raheen Alhamdulillahi khalikal wujoodi minal 'Adam Wa Ja'ilin Noori mina Zulam Wa Mukhrijis Sabri minal 'Alam Wa Mulkit Tawbati 'Alan Nadam Fa Nashkuruhu 'Alal Masa'ibi Ka Nashkuruhu 'Alan Ni'am Wa Nusalli 'Alarasulahila Kramlish Sharathil Asham Wa Nooril Atam Wa Kitabil Makkam Wa Kamalin Nabiyina wal Khatam
Salyadi waladi adam aladi bashrabihi aisab numariyam Wada'alibi aasatihi Ibrahimu alaihis salam Haina kaana yarfa'u kawa'idabaytillahil Muharram Fasallallahu alaihi wa alaihi wa salam wa ala adba'ihi khairil ummam aladina barakallahu bihim kaafsatan nass al araba minhum wal ajam
Wa salallahu ala ameer al mu'mineen al-anza'il bateen waqa'idil quril mahajjalin ghalib ala qulla qalib matloobi qulla taalib Mawlana 'alibnabi taalib Alhamdulillah, al-ladi anzala ala abdihil kitab, walam yaja'allahu aybaja ...
Waalhamdulillah, al-ladi lam yat tashizwaladan, walam ya kun lahu sharikun fil mulk, walam ya kun lahu wal yum minazullay wa kabbirhu taghdira
Alhamdulillah, Alladinahmaduhu wa nastaainuhu wa nastaghfiruhu wa nutminu bihi wa natawakkalu alai Wa na uzubillahi min shururi al-fusina wa min sayyi ayaamalina Man yahdihillahu fala mudillala Wa manu al-bilhu fala hadiyala Wa nashadu an la ilaha illallah Wahdahula sharikala Wa nashadu anna Muhammadan Abdullahi wa rasulih
Arsalahullahu ta'ala bilhuda wadin al-haq liyuzhirahu aladdinikullah wa kafabillahi shaheedah Wa nashhadu anna mawlana ali ibnabi talibwasihu wa waziru fasallallahu alayhim wa ala alayhim wa sallimuum tasliman kathiran kathira Allahum mala 'ilmalana illa ma alamtana inna ka'antal alimul Hakeem Allahum ma alimna bima yanfa'na wa yanfa'na bima alamtana
Allahumma inna na audhu bikamin ailmin la yanfa wa min qalbin la yaksha wa min aimin la tadma wa min nafsin la tashfaa Fa'amma baadi akulu subhanahu wa taalafi kitabihil kareem bada na kula audhu billahim na shaytana rajeem bismillah rahman ar raheem Rabbish rahli sadri wa yaser li amri wahlul qdatam mill lithani yasqahu qawli
Allahum masabitna aimdal mawtibila ilaha illallahu wallahum majalna minal ladeena amanu amir salihat wa tawasaubil haq wa tawasaubil sabr amin ya rabbil alameen once again salam alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu so we were looking at some of these linguistic terminology that is used in the Quran right we began with
understanding what the word ilah means and how it relates to Allah.
We looked at the word rahma which is the primary and the most fundamental or essential attribute of Allah and which is again a composition of these various meanings that we looked at it comes from the root word raham which is the womb of a mother and then we looked at its derivatives which is rahman and raheem
and basically it's a combination of unconditional love, concern, care and mercy or compassion.
So, we have all these different, you know, we looked at all these different subterms or, you know, the components of this term in order to understand what the word Rahma means.
then we looked at the word Arab which is the action of the Creator and which is also a composite word and it is a combination of six things or six characteristics right Arab is a combination of all of these traits he is the one with complete ownership Malik
He is Sayyad, he is the one with absolute authority.
He is Murabbi, he is the one who nurtures, he is the one who guides, who sets to purpose.
He is the Munayim, he showers with undeserved gifts and blessings.
And then he is Qayyim, he is the sustainer, the maintainer, the one who provides.
So, all of this together come, you know, they come together, these meanings to give us an understanding of the word Rab.
Now,
Now, so now that we understand some of these primary terms, the one, the next thing to understand is.
What is he a Rabb of?
Right.
And Surah Fatiha answers that question in which Allah says, Alhamdulillahi Rabbil 'Aalameen All praise and gratitude.
Belongs to Allah who is Rabb and what is he a Rabb of?
He is the Rabb of Al-Aalameen
So in today's session, we'll begin looking at this word Al-Amin and then we will see what the interpretation of Rabul Al-Amin is and what it practically means for us and there are many many interpretations of Rabul Al-Amin you know I'll only talk about one which I think is the most essential for us it's more practical that's just something in theory so we'll look at this term Rabul Al-Amin today.
But I'll begin with first explaining the word.
Aalam because it is not what we generally think of because if you look at any English.
Translation of the word Aalamin you will see worlds right or universe so Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Aalamin all praise and gratitude belongs to Allah.
Who is the master of the worlds who is the master of the universe
Now, this translation of world, it provides a weak, rather incomplete understanding of this word.
You know, just to break it down, the word alamin is the plural form of the word alalam.
Right?
So, in order to understand the meaning of this word, let's first, you know,
So we have to look at actually two words.
So that is 'al 'alam' and then we also have to look at its counterpart which is 'alim'.
Okay?
So if you look at these two words.
'Alam' and 'alim' you can see that they both have the exact same spelling.
Right?
The only difference between 'alam' and 'alim' is the 'fatha' on the 'alam' and the 'qasra' on the 'alim'.
Other than that, they both share the exact same spelling.
right if I remove the Arab on these words you cannot tell which is which so they have but and by now you know we've talked about this enough in the previous sessions that you know that when in Arabic when two words share a common spelling they have a deep connection in their meaning and in this case as you can see they not only just share the spelling they both come from the same root word which is
and what does the word mean it means knowledge so everything we know that everything that derives from a root word has a connection with that root word so is the root word and from that comes out alam and alim so they are all connected with the meaning of knowledge so means knowledge alim is the one
who knows, who comes to know, and Aalam is that which he comes to know of.
You understand?
Aalim is the one who knows, who is the cause, whereas Aalam is that which can be known, the effect.
Right?
Aalim, the knower is the cause, Aalam is the effect.
and the device through which the Alam learns about the Alam is the intellect which in Arabic is called Al-Aqal now we as human beings we can know many many things we can learn about many things but even with all the knowledge that we have gained over the course of years individually or over the course of centuries collectively we still cannot know everything right
We are knowledgeable about certain things, but at the same time we are also ignorant of other things.
As opposed to Allah who knows everything there is to know.
And the word for someone who knows everything about everything, the word for that is Aleem.
Okay?
and again alim also comes from the same root word alim it is the superlative form of the word alim so an alim is someone who has knowledge some knowledge but alim is the one who has absolute and complete knowledge of everything so now we have three words that stem from the same root word alim you have the alam
that which can be known, that which is waiting to be known, that which is waiting to be discovered, waiting to be researched, waiting to be understood, right?
That's the Alam.
And then there is the Alim, the one who studies it, the one who researches it, the one who discovers it.
And in that process of discovery, in that process of research and learning, he comes to know about the Alim.
He comes to know about the one who knows everything there is to know, who is the source of all knowledge.
Now, because we as human beings, because we are limited in our abilities of how we learn something, what the Aleem did, what Allah did is that He created the Aalam for us so that we can study it, so that we can reflect upon it,
and through that reflection we become knowledgeable so that we can become aware so that we can recognize recognize who?
the Aleen you understand so this is what I always refer to as the genius of Allah's design because Allah
you know think about it if you are Allah put yourself in Allah's shoes if you are Allah you are unlimited in your capabilities you have your you're about to create a creation that is going to be very limited in their abilities and yet you want them you want to provide them with a way to recognize you how are you going to do it so when you actually look at it from that perspective you can actually truly appreciate the genius of this design because Allah is infinite in his capabilities right
And infinite means without limits.
Imam Jafar Sadiq alaihis salam, he says, you know, when somebody asked him about the meaning of Allahu Akbar, he said, Allahu Akbar min ay yahaddawa yahsa.
Allah is great in the sense that He does not have a boundary.
He cannot be confined to human comprehension.
In other words, Allah cannot be defined.
You see?
Allah, anything about Allah cannot be defined.
But the reality is that as human beings, we are only capable of understanding things through what?
Through definition.
Right?
Definition is what defines or gives finiteness to something.
It limits reality for us so that we can put it into a perspective.
That is what the intellect does.
It sets a boundary.
It confines, right?
It defines.
You have to wrap, in order to wrap your mind around something, a concept, a definition, anything, you have to confine it first.
So how did Allah solve this problem for us?
The problem of understanding and recognizing an infinite creator through finiteness.
How do you solve that problem?
By creating this Aalam.
Because as human beings, we are limited in our mechanisms of learning something in that we have to define something before we can understand it.
So how do we as creatures of finiteness and definition understand a Creator who is infinite and cannot be defined?
How do we do that?
Through this intermediary of Aalam, which essentially acts like an interpreter.
Everybody knows what an interpreter is, right?
If everyone in this group only speaks English and all I know is Urdu,
then for me to understand what you're saying, I will need a middleman, right?
Someone who understands both languages, someone who can take your messages in English and translate them for me in Urdu, right?
It's that exact same concept with the aalam, which in its creation is physical, but in its design reflects the attributes of its creator.
It defines the attributes of the Creator's glory and His magnificence so that we can gain some understanding about our Creator by studying the Alam.
SubhanAllah.
So in other words, this universe, it becomes a medium through which we can recognize Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Because every sculpture necessitates the presence of a sculptor.
every sculpture necessitates the presence of a sculptor the poet says you know the most convincing evidence that Allah exists is the fact that every sculpture requires a sculptor similarly everything that can be known requires
and necessitates the existence of a knower.
This entire universe has the capability to be known but what good is it without a knower?
Because nothing can exist in a passive state, right?
Therefore the proof of how we know Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala you know the evidence that Allah exists is through the Asaab, through his signs.
the signs and effects left behind in creation.
We study these signs that he created for us in the alam in order to recognize the alim.
Just as the Greek philosopher who asked that Bedouin, right, there was a Greek philosopher, he was passing through a desert and he saw this Bedouin walking and he said, he had just heard that, you know,
because apparently all the philosophy and everything Greek and you know they were really strong in their philosophy so he just wanted to see how does you know how do the Arabs understand the existence of a god so he just asked him he said how do you come how did you come to know of your master the Greek philosopher asked this poor Arab Bedouin right he said how did you come to know of your master and that Bedouin he said
He said the camel dunk shows me that there was a camel here.
I see camel dunk lying on the sand that's showing me that a camel passed by here.
The donkey dunk tells me that there was a donkey here.
Footsteps in the sand tell me that someone walked by this place.
Fasama uzaatu abraj, wal ardu zatul fijaj, wal abharu zatul amwaj.
So when I look at the sky with its perfect constellations, when I see this earth with its perfect valleys and traverses, and when I look at the oceans with all of its waves, ...
...
Do all of them...
do they not indicate the presence of the Latif and the Khabir?
Subhanallah! It was that simple to him, see?
We complicate, you know, we complicate things but the truth is that the existence of Allah is the most clear and the most manifest truth there is, you know, for anybody whose fiqrah is intact.
If that primordial essence of Fitra is intact, the question about the existence of the Creator does not even emerge.
And this is why when the atheist says, you know, I wish that there was more proof for the existence of Allah, the believer replies, I see nothing but the proof of his existence.
It's all around us.
It's in the alem.
So that's the linguistic meaning of the word Alam.
It is anything and everything that can be known by the Alim in order to enable him to recognize the Alim.
And this is why world is not the best translation for the word Alamin.
It limits the scope of its meaning.
If Allah meant Master of the World, then it would just mean that.
and nothing other than the world or universe and in that case the plural form of the word you know of this word Al-Awalim would have been used Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Awalim not Alameen because the use of the word Alameen it you know it the word Alameen it encompasses a much broader spectrum than just this physical world
The statement Rabbul 'alamin, it means that Allah is not just the master of the world or the master of the universe, it means that He is the master of everything that can be known.
So I want you to change your definition of this verse.
Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Alameen Praise and gratitude belongs to Allah who is the master of everything that can be known.
Because everything that exists in creation is a reflection of the Alim.
It exists in a passive state waiting for the Alim
to learn about it through reflection so that he can recognize his creator.
So you see now the definition of Raghbul Alami, it becomes much broader in scope than just master of the world or master of this universe.
He is also the master of all the different species.
He is also the master of all the various groups in creation, right?
Every group, every category
every concept, every idea, every thought, every postulate, every theorem, every physical matter, every chemical matter, every spiritual entity, everything in existence, physical or metaphysical is now included in the definition of the word Aalam because they all exist for one and one reason alone.
so that the Alim can study about it, come to know about it, and recognize his creator the Alim.
Now, there are many explanations of what the word Rabbul Alam means, there are many interpretations.
Today I want to explore just one of those interpretations which I think is the most lacking trait in our society today and that is the trait of humility.
Because Allah points out that it is He who created different cultures and the different creations and the different civilizations.
Allah is the one who created people of different colors, race, languages, you know, social statuses.
you know he says in the Quran ...
right he says I gave you preference over other nations and and if you look ...
and the word he uses for nations in this verse is alameen and by that over here by alameen he's talking about nations so you can just see right here in the Quran
that the word Aalam is not just restricted to world so the idea is that Allah is the creator and the master of all nations He is Rabbul Aalameen so the implicit meaning in that is you better treat these people properly be careful how you interact with them right regardless of their race or religion because don't forget that Allah is Rabbul Aalameen
And why is that important to know?
you know you know what the word means now right we have combined all of those definitions into one word master but it still means all of those things right owner the one with authority the one who provides gifts the one who nurtures all of those meanings but we've combined all of that in in the word master
So it's important to understand this Rabbul Alameen because in our interactions with other people, if we hurt them, Allah is saying that if you hurt them, if you break their heart with their words, you know, if you abuse them with that temporary authority that I have granted you over them, you better not forget that I am Rabbul Alameen.
And this does not just apply to human beings, even animals, plants,
this earth so in that word Rabbul Alamin what the implicit message is that before you're cruel to any of my creation you better remember that I am their Rabb too because when a slave gets hurt by someone who gets offended ultimately the master you know in olden days
wars would begin because the, you know, the member of one tribe hurt or killed the slave of another tribe.
So his master would take that as a personal insult.
Why?
He's a slave.
Nobody disrespected his property, you see.
Slave is a master's property and responsibility.
So even if that slave was in the wrong and deserved to be punished, who should the complaint be taken to?
his master, right?
So Allah says I am Rabbul Alameen so be careful how you interact with my creation no matter what group, what religion, what caste, what belief system, what country they belong to you know no matter what your relationship with them is on this earth it doesn't matter because before he's your son he's my slave
before she's your daughter she's my slave before he's your father before she's your mother they are my slaves before she's your daughter-in-law before he's your son-in-law they are my slaves before he's your employee before he's your servant before he's your student don't forget that they are all my slaves I am here I am watching if you treat them unjustly
if you hurt them, if you degrade them, if you misuse your authority over them, you will have to answer to me because I am Rabbul 'Alameen.
SubhanAllah.
And so, you know, in one of the sermons of Najul Balagha , he explains that what this title of Rabbul 'Alameen does is that it brings
all of us down on the same level in the eyes of the creator it marks and categorizes all of creation as his slaves you see because when there is Rab there has to be an Aad to complete that relationship why did an entire session on that when there is a Rab there has to be an Aad
So no nation, no group is better than another in terms of their race or their color.
If it is better, it is only by whose standards?
If an individual is better or superior than another person, it has to be by whose standards?
Who can be the judge of that?
The master.
and the reason I'm saying this is you know I'm bringing this topic up is because this has become a huge issue in our community today it has become a huge issue in our religion today it has become a huge issue in the world today you know just because we are Muslims or we are Sulaimanis we start thinking that we are better than the rest of the world yes we are I mean we're definitely superior in our knowledge of realities
Right?
We are superior, Alhamdulillah, in the reality, in understanding the realities through our various Ghulum, right?
Mabdamaad and Haqqaiq and all of that.
Yeah, absolutely.
So I'm not taking that away.
Right?
So there's no doubt about that.
but my point is that that does not give us the right to treat other communities or other religions with spite or look down upon them or you know because it's this concept that has been developed now that is like you know we are the old you know everybody is going to hell other than me and that's just not right you know it does not give us the license to look down upon others so I hope you understand what I'm saying
you know because the last time I said this there was a huge riot in the session in the previous group when I said this that you know oh he's saying that soleimanis are not on the right track and this that's not what I'm saying right I'm just saying that if you do believe if we do believe as a group that we are Allah has blessed us with the knowledge of realities
that he has not you know blessed others with that is not a reason for us to look down upon them and this whole statement always drives me insane when people talk say you know when when people say that oh you know he's going to hell he's you know who are you and that's in today's world we are literally afflicted with this disease of superiority and this feeling of having a chip on our shoulders you know whether we admit it or not
And it's not just limited to religion or, you know, everything, money, social status, whatever.
So Allah is in this statement, this is why the statement of Rabbul Alameen is such a beautiful statement because it brings everybody on the same, it levels the playing field.
Don't forget, I am the Rabb.
You are all my slaves.
Superiority in ranks can only exist through the eyes of the master.
Superiority in ranks can only exist through the eyes of the master based on the servitude of the slave, not through the eyes of the slave.
This is why Rasulallah said, The most honorable in the eyes of Allah is the one who is the most pious.
That's it.
Not by any other standard.
Piety is the only standard through which the Rabb measures the rank of the slave.
Because even the highest ranking person is Allah's slave, and the lowest ranking person is also Allah's slave.
I mean, look at what we recite in every azaan, five times a day.
Ashhadwanna Muhammadan, aqduhoo wa rasoolu.
I testify that Muhammad is his slave and his messenger.
Slave before messenger.
Not Rasuluhu wa Abduhu.
It's not Ashadwanna Muhammadan Rasuluhu wa Abduhu.
No, it's Ashadwanna Muhammadan Abduhu wa Rasuluhu.
The highest ranking person who has ever walked this earth, we testify in every prayer that he is the slave of Allah.
then what right do we have to claim superiority over each other?
Right?
I mean if Allah has blessed us with some gifts and the greatest, no doubt, the greatest gift of all that He has blessed us with is Iman, faith.
My point is that that gift should make us more humble when in our interactions with other people, not more arrogant.
Does Quran tell us the story of someone who became arrogant about his title and his rank?
Do you guys remember the story of Iblees?
I mean, what was his statement?
I am better than him.
I am created from fire.
He is created from clay.
Right?
Who was Iblis?
He was an angel, right?
From the Aalam of angels.
Adam was a human being from the Aalam of Insan.
He looked down upon Adam.
They were both slaves of Allah, but Iblis stood before Allah, you know, he stood before the Rabbul 'Alameen and he said, Ana khairum minhum.
I am better than him.
Khalaktani minnan wa khalaktahum minteen.
You created me from fire, you created him from clay.
So, I am better than him.
I mean, how are we different when we say things like, you know, I am Muslim, you are ***** I am better than you.
I'm going to heaven, you're going to hell.
How does that become any different from what Iblees said to Allah?
And look at the result, right?
What do we learn in that story?
What did Iblees' master do with him?
Did his arrogance bring him closer to Allah or did it get him removed from his divine presence?
He got expelled from Jannah, we know that.
So do we really think that an act that Iblees was punished for, Allah would let it slide for us?
That would not be justice, right?
That he punishes Iblis for his arrogance, removes him from his divine presence, but then reward us and bring us closer to him.
That's not possible.
Because you have to understand, when you and I judge each other, you know, when you and I as slaves judge each other in terms of superiority, what position do we place ourselves in?
We put ourselves in the position of Rabb, because Rabb has the right to judge.
Now, does the Quran tell us about someone who did that?
Didn't someone say, Ana Rabbu kumal 'ala, I am the greatest Rabb?
Who said that?
Firaun, right?
Firaun said that.
How did he end up?
And the reality is that Firaun knew that he was human.
I mean, he knew that he was not Rab because he was fully aware of his weakness.
But despite that, despite knowing his true identity, he claimed a station that he was not worthy of.
Did you know that Firaun, he did not like the fact that he needed to go to the toilet?
Because obviously that is not befitting a Rab, right?
So that bothered him.
So he got all of his physicians together and he asked them that, how do I get rid of this problem?
So they told him to eat bananas, lots of bananas.
So he ate bananas for like 40 days.
And then he ended up with a much bigger problem.
Anyway.
So the reason I'm sort of enforcing this is, you know,
Because today this is not, you know, it's not just a Pharaonic problem.
This is a global problem, right?
Everyone wants to become Ilaah, everyone wants to become Mabud, everybody, at some level, everybody, you know, we have become people who want to be worshipped.
But then we forget how Allah has defined us in the Quran, right?
You know and we have created you from some chain of dirt of mud and water mixed together We created your progeny from a vile fluid Who do you think you are?
You know Allah tells these people you know get down off your high horse be a rajul see a rajul the word rajul is used for the one who has
rajala you know who who as they say rajala an farsihi he is the one who comes down off his high horse and puts his feet on the ground that's a rajul someone who comes down off his horse and and puts his feet on the ground he doesn't see himself raised above the earth right he comes down to the level that he came from from dust that's rajul
but you know, we're all...
we've all become people who at some level are just like playing games trying to be ilah and Allah says no, don't be an ilah, be a rajul, be Adam, be Bani Adam, be Adami that is truly accepting Allah is Rabbul Alameen humility, not arrogance is the trademark of a believer
and and this this acceptance of our ubudhiya this acceptance of our slavery right of our servitude to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala it's a heavy burden that we as believers we have to carry this on our back when you carry a burden on your back and you're trying to climb a mountain
If you have a burden on your back and you're trying to climb a mountain, do you bend forward or do you walk upright?
You have to bend forward.
The burden makes you bend.
It makes you humble, doesn't it?
And this is why humility is the essence of spiritual progress.
Malana Ali he says, Man tawada alillahi rafa'allahulahu The one who becomes humble for the sake of Allah, Allah raises him and elevates him in his ranks.
Subhanallah.
I mean this is why the highest ranking person to ever walk the face of this earth.
Right?
Who was that?
Our beloved prophet Muhammad Mustafa .
The greatest ranking man that this world will ever know of was the most humble in his character.
He was marked by humility.
You know, in the Bible, all previous religions, they have prophecies that predicted his arrival, right?
His arrival is being predicted from the beginning of time.
But in the Bible,
that whole paragraph, you know, in which there are so many signs that have been described about his arrival, that he's going to have all these traits, and the greatest sign that has been mentioned is humility.
The greatest mark of his prophethood that was mentioned, that was prophesized was humility.
Wa jaalis saqeena ta libasu hu, wal birrush shi'aru hu, wa taqwa dameer hu, wal hikmata mantik hu hu, wa sidka wal wa fa'atabi aatu hu, wal akwa wal ma'aroofa khulk hu, wal haqqoo shari'a tu hu, wal adlasira tu hu, wal hadiyu imam hu, wal Islama millatu hu, wa Ahmed Ismuh hu.
Ahadi bhi baadalala, wa aalamu bhihi minal jahala, wa arfa'o bhi baadal khamala.
...
all these different predictions of Rasulullah of his arrival in the Bible.
You know, Allah mentions all these beautiful signs, you know, I am going to send you a man from your own nation.
...
his garment will be his peaceful temperament.
his behavior will be kind his conscience will be piety his logic will be wise his honesty and truth will be his nature his dealings with humanity will be that of forgiveness
justice will be his character, all his actions will be just, you know, his nation will be called the nation of Islam, his name will be Ahmad.
So, all of these traits, you know, He will give a nation and, you know, guidance, He will guide a nation and He will bring them out of error.
He will give them knowledge and bring them out of ignorance.
He will be raised after being belittled.
He will become known after being unknown.
And he will gain abundance after scarcity.
He will become
wealthy after being poor you know so all so Allah mentions all of these this is before the birth of the Prophet Allah mentions all of these signs in the Bible he goes on mentioning all these traits about his beloved but then you know after revealing all these beautiful traits and these incredible signs he mentions the greatest sign of all he mentions the last the most prominent sign of the Prophet and what is that
My beloved Prophet is going to be so humble that when he is going to walk among you in such humility that when he puts his feet on dry leaves you will not hear the sound of them cracking under his feet.
Subhanallah.
This is the prophet we follow.
This is the example we follow.
If you want to know why the slave of Allah gained the honor he achieved from his master, it is through this one trait of humility.
And that is what identifies a true believer from a hypocrite.
Humility.
and this is why I feel atheism is such a blatant form of arrogance because the atheist is rejecting something that is the most obvious and fundamental aspect of his existence that he was created because even an atheist cannot say that he was not created he was not born so now if I say that my father created me and his father created him before him
that's what they call dawr, right?
the salsul because it keeps going on and on and on backwards and then where do you stop?
it stops at Adam who created Adam?
all of you came from Adam and Adam came from dust so arrogance does not defeat
the dust it does not befit the dirt because it is constantly trampled upon right so that is recognizing this Aalam the magnificence what are we in comparison to this universe our entire solar system is nothing more than a speck a dot so then who are we so the Aalam is a sign that is showing us who our creator is and what are we in comparison we're nothing we're dirt we're dust
So how does it befit us?
You know Maulana Ali saw a man who was acting arrogantly so he said to him who do you think you are?
Do you not see your true essence?
Your beginning is a vile dirty fluid.
Your end is a disgusting decaying smelling corpse.
you know so this is the first thing to know you know in the path of spiritual progress this is the first thing to know humility to know our station in this world to know who we are where we stand you know we are marboob we are created we will die we will be raised up you know and this understanding this understanding that we are marboob we are not robbed we are marboob
That is the station of a believer, of a true slave.
So, wallahi, I give myself first of all this advice and I give you all the sincere advice that be humble in all walks of life.
You know, don't be arrogant.
Not about our religion, not about anything.
It is the greatest challenge that we all face in our times today because arrogance
is the adhan, it is the call of our times today.
It has become the trademark of success in this world today.
Schools, colleges, work, families, communities, it's all about I'm better than you.
And arrogance does not befit a slave.
It does not befit an obedient slave.
So may Allah grant us all humility and guide us and enable us in walking in the.
Footsteps of our beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam